>> CNN'S CLARE SEBASTIAN HAS
MORE NOW ON HOW THE BATTLEFIELD
IS CHANGING IN EASTERN UKRAINE.
WITH ANALYSIS FROM THE BRITISH
THINK TANK ROYAL UNITED
SERVICES INSTITUTE.
>> UKRAINE'S COUNTEROFFENSIVE
HAS RESHAPED THE BATTLEFIELD IN
A MATTER OF DAYS.
THEY HAVE TAKEN MORE TERRITORY
IN THE PAST WEEK THAN RUSSIA
HAS SINCE APRIL.
SO THE QUESTION IS, HOW DID
THEY DO IT.
I WANT TO BRING IN NEIL MELVIN,
THE DIRECTOR OF INTERNATIONAL
SECURITY STUDIES AT THE ROYAL
UNITED SERVICES INSTITUTE.
WHICH IS I THINK TANK HERE IN
LONDON.
WE ARE LOOKING AT HERE IS THE
MAP OF WHAT UKRAINE HAS
RETAKEN.
THE SECTION HERE.
ESSENTIALLY AN AREA TWICE THE
SIZE OF GREATER LONDON.
REALLY IN THE PAST WEEK.
TELL ME, HOW DID THEY DO IT?
>> WE NEED TRAUMATIC CHANGE,
QUITE THE SURPRISE BECAUSE
EVERYONE HAD BEEN FOCUSING ON
THE SOUTH DOWN HERE AROUND THE
HOUSE ON.
WHERE DO WE SPOKEN BEFORE ABOUT
THE PRESSURE UKRAINIANS HAVE
BEEN PUTTING ON HERE.
THIS AS IT TURNS OUT WAS A
DELIBERATE STRATEGY TO TRY TO
PULL THE RUSSIANS AWAY FROM THE
NORTH AND THEN UKRAINIANS HAVE
FOUND THE GAP IN THE RUSSIAN
LINES.
THEY PUSHED IN HERE VERY
QUICKLY.
THEY HAVE MOVED VERY FAST.
HAVE GOTTEN BEHIND THE RUSSIANS
AND THE RUSSIAN FRONT HAS
COLLAPSED AND SO THIS AREA NOW
HAS TURNED BACK TO UKRAINIAN
CONTROL.
>> STILL IT'S CONTINUING, WE
ARE HEARING THEY ARE CONTINUING
TO TAKE SETTLEMENTS.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THE
OFFENSIVE SORT OF MOVES NEXT?
>> THE CHALLENGE FOR RUSSIA NOW
IS THERE FRONTLINE HAS CLUBS.
THEIR TROOPS ARE RETREATING.
THEY NEED TO TRY TO DRAW A LINE
NOT TO STOP THE ATTACK.
I THINK WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO
IS AT MINIMUM HANG ON TO THIS
AREA CALLED LUHANSK.
WHICH IS IN THIS CORE DONETSK
AREA.
WHICH HAS BEEN THERE.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE DOMINATED
SINCE 2014, WHEN THE FIRST WAR
BEGAN.
THEY CAN'T LET THE UKRAINIANS
INTO THAT SPACE.
SO THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO
PULL BACK, REGROUP AND THE
UKRAINIANS WILL KEEP ADVANCING
UNTIL THEY HIT THIS NEW
FRONTLINE.
THE RUSSIANS WILL TRY TO HOLD
THEM.
>> HOW HAVE WE GOTTEN TO THE
POINT THAT UKRAINE HAS MANAGED
TO THAT QUESTION INTO A CORNER
LIKE THIS?
WHAT KIND OF DIFFERENCE HAS THE
WESTERN SUPPLY OF WEAPONS MADE
HERE?
WANT TO ZOOM IN ON THIS REGION.
>> WHAT WE'VE SEEN REALLY IS A
NUMBER OF.
THINGS FIRST OF ALL, THE
RUSSIAN INITIAL ATTACK PROBABLY
DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH TROOPS.
NOW THEY'VE RUN OUT OF
MOMENTUM.
THEY ARE RUNNING OUT OF TROOPS.
RUNNING OUT OF OFTEN
IRREPLACEABLE EQUIPMENT, USING
THESE NEW NATO STANDARD
ARTILLERY AND ROCKETS THAT HAVE
COME IN.
UKRAINIANS HAVE BEEN DESTROYING
ALL OF THE SUPPLY LINES, THE
STOCKS OF THESE WEAPONS.
SO, IT HAS BEEN A VERY SLOW
PROCESS AND THEN SUDDENLY A
VERY QUICK ONE AS THE RUSSIANS
COLLAPSE AND THEY RUN OUT.
SO, ALSO WITH THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE DONE VERY EFFECTIVELY IS
THAT THEY HAVE COMBINED THEIR
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE ARMY,
THE AIR FORCE, THE GROUND
TROOPS, ROCKETS AND THEY HAVE
MOVED VERY QUICKLY.
SO THE RUSSIANS DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH FORCES TO CONTROL THIS
VERY LONG FRONTLINE AND THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE PUNCHED THROUGH
THAT.
>> THAT'S WHY WE SEE THE RED,
RUSSIAN TERRITORY ON AUGUST
28TH AND BY SEPTEMBER 11TH.
>> EXACTLY.
UKRAINIANS CAME THROUGH HERE,
THEY PUSHED ON TOWARDS COUPONS,
WHICH IS A KEY INFRASTRUCTURE
POINT AND THEN THEY STRUCK
SOUTH.
THE SKI TOWN, THE RUSSIANS HAD
TO BASICALLY FLEE IT IN
DISORDER AND THEN TRY TO
REGROUP BEYOND THE RIVER.
>> I JUST WANT TO SHOW, FOR
COMPARISON, THIS WAS THE MAP
BACK ON APRIL 2ND WE HAD SEEN
ANOTHER SORT OF WHAT RUSSIA
CALL REGROUPING AFTER THEIR
WITHDRAWAL FROM KYIV THERE.
BUT ESSENTIALLY, THEY HAD ALL
OF THIS TERRITORY UP HERE, THEY
HAD TAKEN, THEY WERE STILL
ATTACKING FROM CRIMEA DOWN
THERE.
AND IF YOU COMPARE THAT NOW TO
WHAT WE ARE SEEING, IT'S A NET
LOSS.
>> YES, THE RUSSIANS ARE SAYING
THAT THE POLICE AND INVASION IS
STILL GOING ACCORDING TO PLAN,
BUT WHAT YOU SEE, THAT AS YOU
SAY.
A SERIES OF LOSSES FOR RUSSIA.
THEY'VE COMMITTED TROOPS, FIRST
OF ALL IN KYIV, THEN IN
DONETSK.
THEN DOWN TO THE SOUTH, NOW
THEY'RE TRYING TO POSSIBLY PUSH
BACK.
MAY HAVE LOST UP TO 80,000
TROOPS.
SO 50,000 DEAD.
30,000 INJURED.
THOUSANDS OF TANKS AND ARMORED
VEHICLES.
SO FOR ALL OF THIS, THEY HAVE
SUFFERED ALL THOSE LOSSES.
NOW UKRAINE IS I THINK SENSING
THAT THERE ARE GAPS WHERE THEY
CAN MAYBE MOVE IN FURTHER INTO
THE SOUTH.
15 TO 20,000 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
IN KHERSON ON THE WESTERN SIDE
OF THE RIVER.
THEY CAN'T REALLY GET ACROSS.
UKRAINIANS ARE PUSHING HERE.
IT'S POSSIBLE THE UKRAINIANS
WILL DO A THIRD ATTACK
SOMEWHERE ALONG THIS LINE.
THEY WILL LOOK FOR GAPS WHERE
THE RUSSIANS CAN'T NOW DEPLOYED
TO STOP THEM.
AND THEY WILL TRY TO PUSH AND.
THEY WILL KEEP THE RUSSIANS ON
THE BACK FOOT NOW UP UNTIL THE
WINTER.
>> SO RUSSIA SAYS IT WILL PRESS
ON WITH ITS STRATEGIC GAMES.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE WHAT THAT
MEANS.
NO MELVIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.